so I took the liberty of ordering an  appetizer in case you were hungry they  look great but I'm allergic to corn Oh  histamines to get too hysterical so I'll  just uh I'll move that to the side  oh no you should at least enjoy though  I'm a little anxious ironically for a  speed-dating organizer I'm not good at  first dates me neither  I know and you know I noticed it speed  dating and I thought this guy's as bad  as I am so I thought what the heck  I got his info sheet why not call him  plus you were clearly nervous kind of  endearing I was a complement knucklehead  lob a little ear candy back at it you  have a lovely smile are your cans your  particularly sharp excuse me excuse me  they're pointing it's a sign of good  genetics animals can't investigate  tougher meets with dull canines thank  you well this dates over